welcome back to new rock stars welcome
back to my mom's room my god i missed it
uh it was so freeing to be
a big boy in my own apartment but i said
no no no
the prodigal son must return home to his
mother
this is the big question the big
question might be
when are you gonna start living like an
adult tommy and the big answer is
never uh this is the show that gives you
too much information
about 2 000 foot tall space step parents
covered with armor and ready to destroy
the whole planet if you don't clean up
your room
true story uh my mom asked me to keep my
room a little tidier this morning so
i'm tommy bech told that i'm here today
with my friend
my fellow member of the big head gang
the peaches to my cream the cream to my
peaches mr mt
what's up baby hey what's going on
thomas i am here and i'm ready to get
into some
celestial action yeah celestials are
weird and we gotta talk about them
celestial action is my favorite uh
subcategory on the hub
mt i've been made aware that there is a
new brand of of headwear called
mammoth for guys with big heads and god
i don't normally solicit sponsors but oh
my god if there was ever a company that
needed to sponsor a big question
mammoth if you're listening right reach
out to him come on
give us some hats they make snapchat you
see this dome right now it's free real
estate
it's free real estate this is a pair of
men's large jogging pants that i have
around my head
this isn't a headband okay this is a
belt for
for a large man
as the release date of the eternals
looms on the horizon we are starting to
ask
more questions about the cosmic elements
of marvel comics as they expand into the
mcu
one particular element we've only heard
mentioned in passing so far
are the celestials and what little we've
seen up until this point
hasn't been very nice so that got us
thinking about this week's big question
are the celestials in the mcu actually
evil
it's a great question because the
celestials are a very mysterious race of
people i mean like
ever since they were introduced like
they've pretty much been
surrounded in mysteries so let's get
into this so the celestials
are a cosmically ancient 2000 foot tall
beings covered in armor and their true
origin is unknown but many of the
theories related to their creation are
based on ancient myths and legends from
different species across the universe
and the celestials of course have played
a part in the evolution of life
throughout time
in the universe however their methods
don't always have a gentle touch
they've been known to wipe out an entire
planet here and there but are their
intentions inherently evil
well or are they more like the gods of
myth here on earth or even the old
testament capital g
god god taking a firm and judgmental
approach on humans and their choices
in order to make us better so we'll
examine what we know about the
celestials from the comics but first
let us look at what we know about the
celestials so far in the mcu within the
mcu the celestials are an ancient race
of incredibly powerful beings who are
able to manipulate matter and energy and
as we've said
they are some of the oldest beings in
the galaxy like even older than the
asgardians and they were the original
wielders of the infinity stones because
in guardians of the galaxy vol 1
as the collector is explaining the
history of the infinity stones
we do see essen the searcher using the
power stone to wipe out an entire planet
of robed people who are just trying to
chill not very chill
zero percent cool like if i was you know
at a party and some dude was like hey
got the power stone
gonna destroy everybody on this planet
and be like yo this is not a very cool
party oh not that kind of party bro
and in gardens of the galaxy vol 2 we
are of course introduced to peter
quill's father
ego of the living planet in the mcu he's
a celestial though that's not the same
in the comics he's not a celestial in
the comics but he is in the mcu an ego
is bored with immortality and thinks the
universe is full of
lame inferior life forms which you know
there are a lot of lame inferior life
forms out there but that's not very
accurate ego there's a lot of cool
people
that's right you go to pockets of los
feliz it'd be hard to argue with them
you know there's a lot of landing
inferior like
i think you just took a trip there was
like you know what i got to expand
i got to go bigger i got to go to venice
and he had a plan to reshape the
universe by making every planet an
extension of himself like he plants
seeds on every planet he encounters and
leaves a lot of lonely kids waiting on
the dorp step for pops to come pick them
up and when he does he promptly murders
them because you know
that's what nice dads do that's not true
at all he's a terrible father don't be
like ego
or omni man either of those those are
perfect examples of bad dads
so remember that i can always start
again
make another kid
so our first full-on counter with a
celestial in the mcu not looking so nice
but another destructive force we see in
the mcu is of course
the destroyer armor from the first four
movie
um it's meant to guard odin's vault but
thanks to loki
gets unleashed on the bustling downtown
of puente antigua new mexico like we
don't know the full history of
the destroyer armor within the mcu
however the destroyer armor has a
history in the comics
that ties directly to the celestials
like odin actually created
the armor to protect earth from
destruction by the celestial should they
deem humanity a failure which is
pretty hardcore stuff and i really hope
that we get to see the
destroyer again in eternals because like
that would be fire to see
destroyer fighting celestials that's
huge massive
and there's also the possibility that
thanos could have been unleashed on the
universe
by the celestials like the mad titan was
driven solely by his quest
to create balance in the universe the
desire for balance came from his
experiences as a young purple dude
on titan yes he saw his home planet
crumble under the weight of
overpopulation and dilution of resources
but he could have also been
indoctrinated to fulfill the will of his
father alars
and of course red skull confirmed the
existence of thanos father
during his trip to the soul storm on
vormir in avengers
infinity war you gotta remember we saw
ego give his son peter quill a new
cosmic perspective in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2.
and peter is overwhelmed by this new
celestial point of view
and was instantly on board with ego's
plan so could a similar event have
happened to a young thanos in the past
like ego is a celestial in the mcu and
there's a possibility that alars could
be won as well he was at least an
eternal in the comic books and even if
alars
isn't made a celestial in the mcu he
could still be an eternal devoted to the
celestial's mission
who passed this ideology on to his son
now let's take a look at all the
celestials that we've seen so far in the
mcu
and it's not a whole lot so like you
know don't need to buckle in because the
only one that we've really seen is
essen the searcher from guardians of the
galaxy vol 1
his ability to wield the power stone
indicates his incredible
durability and strength like you need to
have some really good juice in your in
your blood
to be able to wield a big old purple
rock rock
paper rock purple rock final answer
but that's really the only celestial
that we've seen at this point other than
of course we go the living planet that
we see in guardians of the galaxy vol 2.
he doesn't look like the traditional
celestials that we know of in the comics
like those big
robot looking people um it's funny how
like
they look like robots they sort of talk
like robots but they're not robots no
just gods that we do not comprehend
[Music]
ego in volume 2 is presented as a brain
surrounded by planet
um and he was called the celestial in
the mcu but he's not in the comics
of course we also have nowhere the head
uh the floating celestial that
for some reason the collector decided to
turn into uh
capitalism central yeah um it's just
like hey this head is
just floating around here just not doing
anything let's just let's just move in
like uh what do you call
like snails yeah like a hermit crab like
hermit crabs
crabs that's exactly the thing i was
looking for
um just herbert crab living in
celestial's bodies he's waiting for the
next one to float around he's like
come on celestial body i need a new
piece of real estate it's free real
estate
hermit crabs are just snails that worked
out a little bit you know they're just
exactly just ripped snails i i failed
out of
my marine biology degree yeah yeah i
tried i tried my best
you're a marine biologist in my eyes mt
i tried
so we have of course essen ego nowhere
and
obviously lastly we have your quill
people tend to forget that peter quill
is still very much part celestial like
just because his dad is dead
doesn't mean that peter quill just
suddenly suddenly stops having that
celestial
blood in his body so like peter quill
could have those same powers that we see
in guardians of the galaxy volume 2
again
he just needs a power source he needs
that connection to the light so
don't forget like we're probably going
to see something like that pop up in
thor
4. but anyway that's just me on a weird
tangent and some eternals concept art
has presented some more celestials that
we could see in the upcoming film
the first of these is arishim the judge
and in the comics irishman the judge's
celestial who is tasked with judging
whether or not a civilization
on a planet would live or die and he's
the leader of all four celestial hosts
on earth which is great he's been there
for all four
he doesn't miss it so that's nice yeah
and he was there for the flooding of
earth during the great cataclysm because
he was
one of the people that triggered it
after the deviants were stupid and
decided to fire on the celestials why
would you do that deviants
why they're very big they're quite
bigger than you sorry i
don't need to hate on deviance and be
deviant racist
um but that was a very stupid thing
deviants very devious
and this event caused atlantis to be
submerged into the seas 20 000 years ago
so this is very significant to the
marvel cinematic universe because
um namor is probably most likely on the
way
so this second host of the celestials um
will probably get a shout out in
eternals and we might even get a name
ortiz there and he did this because he
judged that the eternals had failed to
protect
the homo sapiens from enslavement by the
deviants which
to be fair they sort of did at the time
and this event became the myth of noah's
ark fun fact like
that flood in um that bible story is
because of
the second uh host of the celestials aka
the great cataclysm
they don't teach you that at sunday
school but they should no just kidding
please don't get mad at me that's not
actually true
i don't remember that from my religion
class uh them being like well if we look
to the book of lee
stan uh marvel we see here the great
cataclysm
from the second host of celestials
caused atlantis to be submerged
no the somehow they skipped that part
you know jack kirby is my favorite
apostle dude that's right
it's 10 out of 10. book of jack and of
course we also have
nezer the calculator and nazir the
calculator's sole duty
is to examine and catalog all data
brought to him by the others and produce
the findings to irish of the judge
and he can project illusions which is
pretty neat because i can't do that
no and
during the fourth host of the celestials
the soviets launched a nuke at him
and his armor totally protect him
however he did make an illusion
that made the crew think that the
missile had fired back at them and it
caused them to freak out so much
that they caused them immense mental
trauma on them and put them on the coma
i would say that's understandable yeah i
get that
that would probably happen to me too
yeah you know if someone fired a nuke at
me
you know i feel like that's the
automatic response that my body would
have it's just
make them believe that uh i i fired a
nuke at them you know which is a great
perk right
of uh being a celestial oh yeah he's
just like you know what
you guys are we'll give you
guys some mental trauma
yes
and he fought the asgardians and lost an
arm but he grew it back instantaneously
so
that's pretty impressive he has
guardians to take an arm off of a
celestial that's
no small feat but very frustrating that
it grew right back they were like we got
him we took his arm off
and then oh no it's growing right back
ah right you can't even brag about that
at the bar later it's like yeah i took
the selector's arm off but it
grew back like two seconds later so i
guess he also
waged war on the watchers which is you
know
pretty weird considering that they're
pretty uh chill and peaceful people
yeah you know sometimes they'd be
watching you while you're doing uh your
private stuff and that's not cool
i would attack them too yeah the
creepers
the creepers
[Music]
and then we of course have hargan the
measurer is a celestial task with
measuring and
quantifying those planets of celestial
survey and there's not too much on him
because he hasn't committed any major
crimes
yet that we know about so i mean he's a
celestial so
he's probably committed a lot of
genocide during his day
during his millions of years of
existence so you're on the list too
hard
[Laughter]
and we have jamaya the analyzer jamia
the analyzer's main function
as a celestial is to analyze the
progression and activities of the
civilizations that the celestials have
conducted their many genetic experiments
on and report them to the leader of the
celestial host
irishman the judge and he participated
in all four hosts to earth
and wrote the jamiah the analyzer's
fractal scriptures
in an indecipherable text and what this
is is that the eternals of view
jamaica's fractal scriptures at to be
like the written word of the celestial
like the celestial bible
and only ajax was able to decipher it
which was considered a monumental
achievement so this is why
ajax is a very important member of the
eternal's team because usually ajax is
the only one that can
communicate to the celestials and you
know understand the celestial
um you know language and what they're
all about and like
but even ajax has a very small picture
of what the celestials are actually
doing because they still
remain very uh mysterious because they
don't really treat humanity all that
seriously but fun fact in the gardens of
the galaxy film while the guardians are
waiting to meet the collector they are
waiting at a
bar called the boot of jamaica this is
no respectable establishment
so that is a direction to the celestial
gemia but
there are some potential celestials in
the mcu that haven't
been revealed yet that i think might be
revealed in the future and i think
the collector is one of those celestials
and here's why my friend
is because there is a celestial called
gaming the gatherer
and his job is obviously to gather up a
lot of these like
people and and beings on these planets
to actually do the experimentations on
and what does the collector do
he likes to collect stuff i i think that
there's something that happened in the
past
uh for some reason that really condensed
these huge celestials down into humanoid
beings
and so the collector is gammon on the
gatherer and the grand master
is actually zero in the tester because
if you look at the grand master's
clothes in thor ragnarok the colors
underneath his gold jacket anyway are
very um similar to that of zero the
testers
so i think that something happened in
the past there that caused
uh gamma and uh zirin to become
humans and so like the there might be a
weird like tie between the elders of the
universe
and the celestials that we haven't seen
yet but that's just
me being a weirdo
i like it i like it but those are the
celestials in the mcu or potential
celestials in the mcu
um but let's get into some celestials in
the comics
like often referred to as space gods by
many races
there are 22 known celestials though the
number has shifted a little throughout
time and
there's different versions of different
universes that have different types of
celestials we won't get into that
and they have visited the earth four
times over the ages in these events
they call hosts which aren't very um you
know
hospitable events but they they call
them hosts and of course
after the second host they flooded the
planet and they claim that it was for
our own good but
uh did we really smell that bad did we
really smell so bad that they needed to
flood the entire planet
i don't think so celestials i don't
think so because that's a that's a
big-ass bath that's a big bath yeah
and here are some notable moments that
we've seen of celestials in the comics
because
um even galactus was fearful of the
celestial's power because he once
confronted a group
of mad celestials from another reality
stating that he knew their true purpose
and this really pissed them off and they
tried to destroy him and their violent
response to galactus statement
certainly points to the idea that their
intentions are ultimately
not good but reed richards was actually
once able to harm the celestials with
some of his technologically advanced
weaponry because that man is one of the
smartest i've ever seen in
my days
um this is one of the rare moments
showing a celestial's
weakness i mean other than that time
that uh you know celestial's arm got cut
off
yeah and then it grew right back got
better and with the fantastic four
coming to the mcu soon
this would be a crucial addition to
earth's defense against a future attack
from the celestials so uh reed richards
coming to town
would be a really great way to uh defend
ourselves from a future
celestial attack if the eternals end up
failing that's so
read richards better hurry them
and a deviant claims that the celestials
were the ones who created the deviants
in the first place which is
very true because when the celestials
came down to um every planet but when
they came down to earth
they made the eternals and the deviant
races along
with the um you know the branch humanity
timeline with all of our
cool stuff in our dna like the x gene so
those are some notable moments with the
celestials in the comics but here are
some villainous acts of the celestials
in the comics because
they do some pretty bad stuff like
creating the death seed for example
like this device can reanimate the dead
and force them to do the bidding of the
wielder
of the death seed which good god uh
wouldn't it be funny just to see your
you know
a deceased grandma just uh just doing
the will of a
an evil person and this could be the
celestials or anyone else that is
in direct possession of the death seat
so that's pretty bad and they also
created the black vortex which is
basically a mirror which could show you
your ultimate cosmic potential
and if you submit it to the black vortex
you would be granted the promised powers
and the first people to receive the
black vortex the viscardi ultimately
wiped each other out
over its power so that's you know it
sounds like a great thing but it
i guess it'll it'll really just mess up
your neighborhood so you know just don't
don't mess with the black vortex it's
like one of those fitness mirrors
[Laughter]
it really is the black vortex
also led to the destruction of the crown
homeworld of holla so that's
pretty significant to um you know the
overall pre-history and the mutant
apocalypse utilized celestial technology
to carry out his evil deeds well maybe
not directly an evil attack
by the celestials but as in the
searchers intervention into the
life of apocalypse uh really set some
dominoes up to some really
unfortunate things that apocalypse would
do to the mutants
and you know earth in general later on
so
thanks celestials thanks a lot you idiot
and they destroyed many civilizations
and even entire planets when they deemed
them a failure of genetic manipulation
and they've killed trillions of living
beings across the galaxy so
that's a pretty villainous thing to do
and of course they pitted
the cree and the skrull against each
other by manipulating across
time and space this was done to create a
genetics arms race
and often result in the creation of
superpowered variants like
super scrolls and decreased genetically
evolved rule
race which is something that i haven't
really thought about in a while
um and this often leads to catastrophic
events
and they of course created the mutants
for the purpose of igniting a genetic
war
between humans and these human variants
take whoever you believe in every day
that celestials aren't real because yeah
i would have a lot of
anxiety yeah looking up at the sky like
is it today lord
is it today in conclusion the celestials
are not
inherently evil it's more that they
possess a complete indifference about
the loss of life
on an individual scale they're looking
at the long evolutionary line of the
universe
and what must be done to keep it moving
forward and improving this is the
opposite perspective of a group like the
avengers who see
every life as precious of course because
you know we're here on earth and we you
know experience earth but because
they live life on a much grander scale
they just like who cares like you know
like i said previously in another video
it's like do you care about what
goes on in the life of an ant outside
not really we're not really thinking
about that
so it's just like we're sort of ants to
them
and but like other ants you know sort of
value the lives of their
of their other buddies because like
that's where they live anyway
the celestials observe the universe on a
completely different scale
across the whole of space and time and
we as mere humans cannot begin
to understand the reasons behind any of
their decisions and as loki said in the
universe
an ant has no quarrel with a boot ant
boot however from the perspective of a
single life form just trying to exist
within its short
time of life in the universe the actions
of the celestials especially something
like the destruction of an entire
species
can be seen as completely evil and
horrific because you know
that's you one would not blame a person
exp
currently experiencing the death of
their you know planet just
to think that hey maybe these celestial
guys are a little bit evil yeah but like
you know
it's just a matter of perspective yeah
which is weird
because they are doing some pretty
messed up stuff and because of their
seeming immortality the celestials could
be seen as beyond the paradigms of good
and evil like
the reasons behind their actions are
truly unknowable
and the celestials see all life as
merely an experiment
they don't bother to explain their
actions to mere mortals so we are left
to draw our own conclusions from the
choices that they make
because they're never doing to explain
that to us ever later calculations
are unknown to us and if it comes up
that we are to be destroyed
they don't care about our thoughts and
opinions on that because you know
it's just another planet that you've
destroyed there's just so many planets
in the cosmos that are just like all
right
that's planet 1 trillion 2005 gone
on to the next one right so what do you
think tommy are the celestials good
or evil i think they're a lot like an
older cousin
you know like uh it just depends
uh they're not gonna tell you why
they're doing the things that they're
doing but it might
what they're doing might result in you
having a very good time maybe you're at
an amusement park for the day
or it might result in you having a very
bad time
you all end up in jail so
i think it just depends like they are uh
they're truly they seem like most uh
ancient
gods they're emotional basket cases that
behave
uh irrationally on whims of uh
of however they feel are they evil i
don't know that they're necessarily
evilly intended are they good
far far from often good so i'd say
they're pretty good at being evil
i i do like that and i love that you
compare them to
an older castle
it just depends on his shirt celestials
are like your older cousin
it really just depends
it's just a bit yeah yeah so i wouldn't
say that they're evil
they're just like they're just doing
their thing and we just can't comprehend
it yeah
we're just we're just ants it's it's
pretty upsetting and it gives me
like a little bit of an existential
crisis because we really are small yeah
in the grand scheme of things i'm gonna
take an anxiety pill after this
don't worry about it it's fine i'm gonna
go take a peek
[Laughter]
we are going to dive into our bite-size
questions
next but first a word from some of the
folks that help us bring you big
question
you don't have to be unhappy with your
smile thousands of people have used
candid the clear comfortable
removable practically invisible liners
to straighten
their teeth not me look at this this is
a mouth only a mother could love
this one is buffalo this one is
rochester
and right here is route 90 baby this
is route 90. all right hey man you got a
great smile man
thank you just like real customer justin
m from atlanta or as i say hotlanta
and they hate it uh who used candid to
get rid of the gap
between the front teeth that used to
draw unwanted attention
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist that's good
i used an unlicensed orthodontist and
that's how i ended up here
uh his name was peter he was very shy
and most of his tools seem to be things
that he
found in like a model airplane kit
including glue he sounded very confident
outside the home depot
he was when he lured me in he was super
confident but he got really shy once the
work began
you'll have the same quality of care you
get from an in-office orthodontist from
the comfort and convenience of your home
because i want all major dental
decisions to be made
uh from my bed right next to my
playstation 3. that's right
i said three i'm two generations behind
with candid the same orthodontist who
created your plan is with you from start
to finish
the average candid treatment is just six
months though you'll start seeing
results
way before that and it costs thousands
less than traditional braces
become your best you start straightening
your teeth today
right now you can save 75 on candid
starter kit go to candid co.com
big question and use code big question
that's candid
co.com big question
code big question take advantage of this
limited time offer to save 75
on your starter kit candid co
dot com slash big question code
big question my design expertise is
relatively low
and when i need to design something it
takes too long
and comes out not looking as good as i'd
like i tried to start a business called
tommy's toys uh it was a line of action
figures based on
nightmares that i had as a child so
instead of spider-man
there was man made of spiders there was
just literally a bunch of plastic
spiders
that combined to make a man instead of
superman
there was soup or man oh my god there
was a big bowl of soup
made of man parts okay anyway
tommy's toys did not do well we were
unable to get a design
off the ground however now that i have
canva pro my designs are next level and
we could be going into
toy stores are kb stores toys still open
tommy's toys might be in there next
month now that i have canva pro
canva pro is the easy to use design
platform
that has everything you need to design
like a pro it's a quick
easy and affordable way to design
whatever you need canva pro has a
collection
of over 75 million premium photos videos
audio and graphics and if you don't like
those just text me and i'll record
something for you
plus canva pro comes with time-saving
tools that simplify
and speed up the creative process my
favorite canva pro feature
is the one-click background remover with
one click you can cut out the background
of a photo
so you can drop your dog into any mcu
movie memes
in record time and god knows i need that
for my apartment oh my god which is
pathetic
so when i'm on bumble i can cut out my
apartment
and put a brick interior maybe with a
fireplace
maybe with a mounted bear's head in the
back so they know that i'm rubbing it
outdoors
you already know what the girls on
bumble like bro you already
know that's right there's no idea too
big or too small for canva pro there are
some ideas that are too stupid like
tommy's toys
it's great for startups students
marketing teams non-profits
entrepreneurs crafty moms princesses
jocks
it's great for folks trying to start
online businesses or
just folks that want to step their
social media game up design like a pro
with canva pro
right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial
when you use my promo code just go to
canva.me
question to get your free 45-day
extended trial that's
c-a-n-v-a dot m-e
slash big question canva dot me slash
big question all right it's time to just
take out your little bag of gold fish
time for a little bite little num num
snacks
it's time for bite size questions baby
what do you got for me empty
bite size question well the first bite
size question of the day tommy is
why are some cree blue and some are not
this is from geo fishy on discord
so that's a great question as we saw in
the mcu films such as guardians of the
galaxy and captain marvel
the cree are a race of aliens that
resemble humans almost exactly
in their physical appearance except for
they are fine
as hell not an ugly korean sight
no sixes no sevens all eight to nines
and tens
no no six and above
some cree have blue skin tones such as
ronin the accuser and
minerva however other cree like john
rogue and marvel do not
the film never explains the difference
but we can turn to the comics
but the answer once again thank you
comics yes
we're always answering those questions
where the writers of a film
don't know how to explain the cree we're
all originally blue skinned living on
their home world of
challah as they traveled to other worlds
they began to breed with other species
hello cree
having some fun on vacation oh i've gone
to another planet
now i've had a baby cue the tick tock
meme of i'll never forget you to the
cree
that i met on the beach in myrtle beach
here's your son he's greed over the
millennia a new group of three
emerged with pink skin more closely
resembling a caucasian human
eventually the pink skin decree
outnumbered the blue skin cree
the blue skin crease saw themselves as
purebred which is always a great sign
and maneuver to hold a majority of the
power in the government
the pink skinned cree are more durable
than the blue skin cree
thanks to their evolutionary growth the
differences between the cree races has
played a major role in the comics before
but we will have to wait to see if it
ever comes into play in the mcu
we i wonder if there's going to be a a a
creta a creature luther king
no matter rise up i feel like that's the
end i think the mcu will be unable like
they're not going to be able to handle
that like they're they're just like no
we're just not talking about it they're
all fine they're all equal they're all
equal
[Laughter]
like we don't want to have to deal with
the realities of this no all right okay
oh man i i wonder if they ever will
address like the the racial tensions
in in the disney movies because like no
kidding man
like that that was a pretty a big point
of contention in the creek culture and
like yeah
weird for them not to cover that yeah if
one if one if
one of any culture believes themselves
to be the purebreds
there's a point of contention for
there's a boat there's a there's an
issue
i mean we sort of get a glimpse of of
this with with ronin
right his whole um his whole d ordeal in
the first movie and the first guardians
movie because
he's all about like the his his
ancestors and like
following the true path of like a true
purebred cree
so uh but we do see that he has a a
black friend
a black cree friend on board so like
maybe he's that's true
he's cool with some i don't know i don't
know what it broke he's slightly more
evolved
than the cree that we're hearing about
in the comics but
i'm not giving him full i'm not going to
give him something he's still got a
black friend
listen i have one black friend you have
to stop saying that at parties we get
it we understand it's not it's not
making you look
better and our next bite size question
of the day is did captain america rack
up any back pay for the military while
he was frozen in ice
this was from golden horseshoed on
twitter
great question pretty great name golden
horseshoe golden horseshoe
all right when steve rogers went into
the ice in 1945 he was still an active
member of the military while they may
have
initially listed him as k.i.a or guild
in action
or possibly just mia or missing an
action in 1945
they did eventually discover him alive
in the ice
would steve have been accruing back pay
during that whole time did he
wake up in 2011 with a fat bank account
i hope i hope they were putting it i
hope it was in a savings account that
was accruing interest
well good news we're in luck because the
army has officially weighed in on this
question
i don't know if we're in luck because of
that oh shoot the actual united states
army
good news your tax dollars network
led to the army fielding feeling this
question
in 2016 army spokesman
wayne hall stated i'm sure after an
exasperated sigh
[Laughter]
it's all right i'll answer your question
fine if captain steve rogers aka captain
america were not a fictional character
in the circumstances surrounding his
disappearance and recovery
actually real he may actually be
entitled to receive back pay
however a wide variety of variables
would have to be taken into
consideration
to actually calculate the true amount of
back pay to which he would have been
entitled to
receive at the time steve went into the
ice he was a captain
at the 03 pay grade in 1945 his
compensation was about
313.50 per month
taking that into consideration along
with the standard increases in pay over
the years
and the possibility that captain rogers
could have been bestowed promotions
well listed as missing steve should have
woken up with
at least three million dollars
being owed to him by the us army what
what what
three million dollars
wow are you kid like that's if i was
captain america civil war would have
started over that i'd be like
that's a lot of steak mashed potatoes
and peas with peggy carter oh my god
like this dude was rocking with this
vibranium let's check out this rock
yeah that's a rare rock
yeah you guys got your goal like i'm on
a vibranium rock
wow
are great questions we've we've we've
rifled through all of the quality
we've gone through all of the bite size
and now all that's left is to dig
through our box of scraps
a box of scraps that's a square it's
just a box of scraps yes
so unboxing scraps question
mt summer is almost upon us
it's uh a lot of people are claiming
this summer for a lot of different kind
of people but i have this
to say this is all there's only one
summer
it's big head summer baby it's big heads
gang summer
this is the summer of large craniums
and vibraniums okay we're getting it in
it's gonna be very painful uh big head
summer all right so you already know bro
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna take this big head tannic
that's gonna be even browner than you've
ever known
i am ready and this had two somehow uh
so what fictional land would you like to
visit
on a trip to this summer what fictional
land
would you like to visit on a trip this
summer hmm
that's a great question do you guys
answer to this one uh
i do i do uh for me
it's a place i've always wanted to go
and that is the
uh that is the cloud city that is the
cloud
i want to go to the cloud city oh my god
that's a great destination land of
uh scoundrels smugglers thieves i want
and i'm talking pre-imperial occupation
cloud city
i'm talking when it was run like vegas i
mean i want
i want to go there i want to gamble i
want to play all those weird dice and
card games
i want to visit the twilights and their
pleasure gardens
i want to do it all okay it's gonna
happen for me on cloud city
uh i may even fall in love honestly
straight up that's the land of lando bro
like that is the best hell yeah place
hell yeah to be
it's so beautiful it's so beautiful it's
one of my favorite like
lands oh my god when i was a kid it
actually helps me answer this question
when i was a kid i thought that there
was like if there was ever a way for
cloud city to become real i would do
anything to live there when i was
when i was eight factual factual because
it's just so beautiful like they did a
really great job and
was it episode five when they were when
they introduced the cloud so that's
correct
um just like bringing that place to life
yeah just looks so
good um to this day it holds up like the
whole production value just
holds up to the scene absolutely um but
speaking of star wars uh you actually
helped me think of and answer this
question when you said um cloud city i
was thinking
oh i always say that like my number one
star wars destination
is naboo from oh yes because
it was just a beautiful freaking planet
i love naboo it's my favorite planet if
i were to live anywhere
yes in star wars it would be that green
luscious planet great answer
gungans unfortunately oh my god yes well
hey oh you know it's got to be
even paradise has a few rough edges you
know
it's like how do we explain their
accents
is it wrong yes is it uh
who is it for i don't know i don't know
i guess it's for george lucas
at the end of the day that had to have
just made him happy everything in the
goongaz
and that's not okay but it is
sad reality all right so we are both
taking
star wars vacations this summer i love
it
i know we're nearing the end because my
face is hurting from smiling and
laughing with you my friend
that's it for this episode of big
question
thank you as always to mt for joining me
this episode
please follow him at mastertainment you
can follow me at tommy beck told
follow new rockstars send us your big
questions using the hashtag bigquestions
subscribe to this podcast feed
give us a nice rating and review
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube hit that notification bell
we will see you next week with another
big question
goodbye
[Music]
you